we're all just stories in the end so
make it a good one so I've had a couple
of folks who follow this channel and
comment regularly asked me about doing a
ranking of the series finale for all of
the series up to this point series one
through ten and I debated it initially I
didn't think I was gonna do that cuz I
kind of feel like my thoughts on the
various finales get covered in a lot of
the other lists that I do and that's
true to a certain extent but I struck on
something that I do now want to do this
but the first thing I'm gonna do is I
need to establish that on this occasion
this one occasion probably one will say
I am breaking my main rule with ranking
Doctor Who episodes every other list
I've ever done up to this point I've
counted two parters has only one story
this time I'm not doing that I am
looking only at the final episode itself
not the immediately preceding one which
is pretty relevant because most of these
are two-part stories why am i suspending
this rule that I normally go by well
because if I don't then I'm gonna have
to keep touching again and again and
again and again and again on one being
better than the other whether the second
one is better than the first one or the
first one is better than the second one
and then sort of explaining how they
balance and like and I'll probably still
touch on that to a certain extent but I
don't I I really want to talk about the
final thing we got for any given series
the last go the last impression this was
how everything closed out not just the
immediate story but the series so only
last episodes on their own so on that
basis I'm doing 10 because I'm not gonna
deal with the Tennant specials they
weren't they didn't really have a proper
series finale in my mind I mean I
suppose you could count end of time part
two but I am opting to not address that
one here so that means we have series 1
through 10 so let
start at the bottom you all know what it
is I will keep it short because I have
ranted plenty about it
hell-bent what a freakin mess this
episode I god I hate this episode but I
I'm gonna restrain myself from ranting
and raving and screaming about it this
time but to reiterate briefly this
episode undermines two brilliant
episodes that came before face the Raven
and having said it undermines the death
of Clara by effectively bringing her
back from the dead and no it doesn't
matter that she's gonna go back and
eventually meet that death because she
can do it she can fly on the universe
for as long as she wants until that
happens effectively she's become
immortal until she chooses not to be
that's not that that is a complete
undermining of her death and it
undermines Heaven Sent because Heaven
Sent was all about the doctor coping
with his grief but now oh hey look at
that she's not dead anymore and on top
of that he doesn't even remember her so
he doesn't even remember having to have
grieved for her in the first place and
then in addition to that it is a lousy
payoff for the very long build-up return
to gala to Gallifrey of the doctor and
it's thrown away for this whole thing
with him going to extreme lengths to
save Clara I hate this episode let's
move on number 9 the wedding of River
Song people were probably expecting this
to be towards the bottom of the list
anyway because it cropped up on my worst
episodes written by Moffat list and it's
just kind of higgledy-piggledy
convoluted it's a bit of a mess it
doesn't make me angry the way that hell
bent made me angry but between the
explanation for how the doctor didn't
actually die which is a weird cop-out
that doesn't make a complete and total
sense to seeding this really awesome
idea all of time happening at once and
then not really do anything doing
anything of note with that having a
couple of cool moments that just don't
add up to a heck of a lot and I like
river but she just feels that this feels
like her most obligatory appearance at
least in my opinion number 8 the Big
Bang I know a lot of people really like
this one
people list this two-parter is one of
their favorites here's the thing and
this is the first time I'm gonna have to
mention you know in relation to the
two-part two-parter Pandorica opens set
up a lot of interesting stuff and had a
hell of a cliffhanger Big Bang Theory
doesn't feel like a story to me it feels
like a logical puzzle it feels like an
exercise in tying up loose ends it
doesn't feel like a story it doesn't
engage me emotionally it doesn't hook me
in with what the characters are going
through it's just going look while I do
this magic trick to fix that setup that
I just I ended the universe and
everything in ha and the entire universe
gets rebooted think about that for a
second previous episode the universe
ended all of it and there's no lasting
ramifications from that none that there
have been a lot of deus ex machina
episodes and deus ex machina finales
especially in history of the show in my
mind this is the most egregious one
because it removes any ramifications
from something that should have had
massive consequences and just doesn't
and it keeps introducing plot elements
and then dropping them because it
doesn't wanna have to tie up that end
like young Emilia like how do we deal
with the fact that we've got an older
and younger version of Amy here oh never
mind little version of Amy's gone by
there's still moments that ring true the
there's a sense of triumph when Amy
remembers the doctor and he comes back
that does actually still work there are
some sad moments and so there's enough
bits that click that it isn't lower than
this and it didn't show up on my worst
episodes that Moffat wrote lists but I
consider this episode incredibly
overrated by a lot of fans number 7 the
last of the Timelords yeah again a bit
of a deus ex machina where you know how
do we fix the doctor he's always oh oh
look he's magically back and I like that
in and of itself I can almost kind of
roll with because I'm a sucker for
stories about the power of stories so
the idea that Martha
spent a year just going around the world
telling the story of the doctor and the
strength and power of historian is
legend restoring him it's a little
cheesy but I can kind go there except
we're also gonna roll things back undo a
year worth of Hell so that there's no
lasting consequences to the fact that
the entire earth got invaded and and you
know the only people who remember are
these hands full of people like that if
you're not gonna pan out the
consequences for a big event don't do
the big event because then it's just for
show at that point there are some decent
parts in it I think the death of the
master is definitely a good part it's
well handled I really love this twisted
sense of triumph he has when he's dying
in the doctors arms and you know there's
bits like that there's stuff like that
that works but on the whole this is just
kind of its I was gonna say it's
functional I'm not even entirely sure
it's that number 6 death in heaven we're
starting to get into the episodes that
I'm more or less like and don't have a
ton of problems with but you know
they're just at least for me gonna get
better and better and better as we go up
so death in heaven it squanders a couple
of good ideas that probably shouldn't
have been tied to it like the
nethersphere that I'm not entirely sure
why that's here and why it's necessary
in terms of connecting it to the whole
Cyberman thing like I'm not saying I
don't understand the explanation and the
logic of what they do I get it
I mean matically I don't understand what
the whole thing with retaining dead
people does to actually add to the story
if we're dealing with potential Cyberman
evasion but the two don't build and on
each other in a particularly coherent
way or a way that elevates much that
said I I mean I love Michelle Gomez's
Missy she's a lot of fun I actually felt
that Danny had a pretty good send-off as
a character as far as these things go
and the little note that is given to the
Brigadier I you know some people can
call it fanservice yap fine sure it's
fan
service but for me it worked and I was
and I was down with that so this is a
this is a decent one it's good it's fine
but there are better
number-5 journey's end this has a number
of things going for it that just work
really well I mean first off Donna and O
talked about this before the the Donna's
loss of memory kills me every time and
when she's begging him to not do that to
her that she she she is making the
choice that she would rather die then
lose all this and he takes that choice
away from her and that's that's tragic
that's really really sad and it's also
important because it helps mitigate what
is otherwise a bit of a deus machina
resolution where all of a sudden Donna
is able to magically do all this stuff
and defeat the Daleks and one go but the
reason that that doesn't completely ruin
it is there are consequences after that
yes she swooped in and saved the day but
it's not gonna stay good not from not
even for very long and I I do kind of
wish that like there was more of a point
to giving Rose her own aging Doctor
clone besides just I don't know making
fans of Rose happy I suppose so that was
a little weird but Davros works really
well in this episode it maybe gets a
little too indulgent with the goodbyes
but nothing compared to end of time part
2 certainly but this is one where it's
starting to find the balance between
what works and what and what doesn't and
we are starting to get into the ones
that I do I do really genuinely enjoy
number four the name of the doctor I had
a bit of an internal debate about where
to place this one because part of me
wants to bump it down in my estimation
given
where a lot of it went like I don't
in hindsight I really don't like the
larger implications of what was done
later with the fact that car was
scattered across his timeline I mean
that's part of the the whole hybrid mess
with with Hell Benton and everything
that was so wrong with that
and I don't like that it has its roots
in here but if I take that aside and I
don't deal with what happened later as
an impact of this episode and just in
with the episode on its own yeah I
really like this I feel like the build
up towards the presumed death of the
doctor is good and well done and feels
properly intimidating and scary I love
Richard II grant as the great
intelligence the whisper men are
throwaway monsters they're better than
the snowmen though give me y'all give
him that much but Richie grant does so
much to sell the obsessive nature and
the intensity of the hatred this
character has for the doctor and I love
that he willingly sacrifices himself not
to enact some greater plan or do
accomplish some greater scheme but just
to be sure that he wins and kills this
guy I I think that works so well and I
mean that cliffhanger holy crap holy
crap that what a killer ending that was
again payoff for it was but yeah I do
really like this episode even though a
lot of what fed directly off of it after
I have issues with number three the
party of ways this is honestly a big
part of why I disconnected the two
partners and dealt with these episodes
on their own cuz I don't like bad wolf
as an episode I I don't like it very
much at all actually
but I do enjoy the party boys I like it
quite a bit
I love the doctor you know not
setting everything up but not being
willing to do it which is a recurrence
of stuff we've seen from before going
back you know to Genesis of the Daleks
and things like that so I like how we
get that aspect of him I
I love how threatening the Daleks
themselves are the goodbye that that he
gives to Rose both you know when he
actually regenerates and even the
hologram one are wonderfully touching
the bad wolf thing is something the in
terms of it taking of Rose is something
I've gotten better with over time and
maybe this is cheating because it's
taking into account stuff that happened
way later but it's a it's part of my
assessment of this so I'm tossing it in
there I'm much more okay with it now in
the wake of day of the doctor versus
when I saw it for the first time because
having met the bad wolf entity in that
episode and getting a better sense of it
being scattered and and being a
recurring thing and and now feeling like
I understand it has an entity that
possesses are as opposed to this weird
thing that just happens when she looks
into the TARDIS what I I this all works
much better for me than it did the first
time that I watched it and yeah I like I
said maybe that's cheating but hey it
bumped it up for me number two
doomsday this one's high up on the list
for primarily cheesy reasons it's Daleks
versus Cybermen how can you not love
that and also this is another one that
benefits from not being attached to the
previous episode because army goes is
fine it's an easy setup but it's not a
great episode of never self this oh so
much fun and the return of the Daleks is
probably the best it's been in terms of
like the about you of oh god they're
back it hit better here than it ever did
anywhere else
I'm person because they come back every
year but that's another conversation so
we've got that and then you know the
triumph of getting rid of them and then
rose and that wall and the music kicks
in
and the weight of it and the sadness of
it oh oh it does hit you like I revised
this list a couple times and this for a
time was in the number one spot it came
really close because the stuff I like
about it I love but there are little
nitpicks like that opening with roses
narration like this was the day I died
that was cheap and unnecessary it is
possibly maybe a little too fanservice
II but I would argue that it's
fanservice that works and you know
Mickey coming back and coming back was
nice but a little just conciliatory and
but these are minor things like there's
just a thrill and a fun and then
ultimately a sadness of this episode it
just works really well so if you've been
keeping track with your checklist and
going through process of elimination you
know what my number one is and I didn't
think this was gonna be my number one
because I remember when I first saw it I
was initially a little disappointed with
it but that was only because of the
previous episode being even better so
that means it's time to talk about what
I feel is the best series finale of
Doctor Who the doctor falls and it this
does I this episode in isolation does
benefit from no longer being attached to
world enough in time because it looks
worse in comparison but when I actually
do take them apart and look at it as its
own entity I love this there's so much I
love about this and the the whole thing
with Bill and talking with the doctor
and we see her both as the Cybermen and
as bill so that it never lets us forget
what she now is but at the same time we
don't lose the interaction and the
chemistry between these characters and
these actors who are so good together
and the sadness of the doctor having to
answer our questions when she asked you
said you could fix me were you lying no
were you right no he thought he could
fix this but he can't not this time
the intensity from Capaldi when he is
just shouting at the master and then
pleading with him just do it because
it's
right do it because it's kind and that I
really felt like the perfect
encapsulation for for Capaldi's doctor
be kind yes they just felt like it said
everything
nardole has some nice moments the whole
thing with the different times on the
different floors it's playing out in
interesting ways Missy and the master
plays out in a good way and just her her
laughing like that you fool
yeah it just it feels right and in so
many ways having learned more about how
twice upon a time came into production
basically only because if they didn't
you know Chris Chibnall wasn't planning
to do a Christmas special he what he
wasn't ready to do that and if they
didn't have a Christmas special they
were gonna lose that slot and possibly
not get it again and that that's why
twice upon a time happened and now you
know knowing that about the production
of that I I kind of wish it hadn't
happened I mean I I don't know if I'm
prepared to say it would have been worth
losing Christmas specials forever but I
really kind of wish that the doctor
Falls was Capaldi's last episode because
I just feel like it's a stronger finish
it feels better it feels more right
whereas twice upon a time which is an
episode I like actually quite a bit but
coming off of this that feels like an
artificial lengthening where this the
doctor Falls feels like the natural end
for Capaldi and it feels right and I'm
not I'm not one of those hosts is gonna
be like in my head there is no twice
upon a time I selectively had Kenny I
don't do that but yeah I will always
kind of wish that this had been his
closeout up sewed because I just think
it's a stronger finale for him as a
character and I think it's personally I
think it is the best series finale of
Doctor Who in the modern era
that's my ranking you probably disagree
with me so why don't we talk about it
job something down in the comments give
your thoughts on my list give me your
own list just be polite about
so there's that and then there's all the
things like liking and subscribing and
supporting me on patreon and buying a
t-shirt and Twitter and podcasts and
blare links for all that stuff is down
in the description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]